monsieur le
présidentz
bienenuant en
votrene la
rieia la France est heureuse de saluer
une nation avec laquelle elle entretient
depuis longtemps les liens de la plus
étroite amiti vre voyagesie présidentita
dneoastnu pr
vous să vizitați nu numai capitala
noastră ci și provinciile
noastre și să
Cuno tot atât de bine bogățiile noastre
artistice cât
șii con AC astfel veți putea face
cunoștință Cu franța
tradițională și suntem animați de
dorința de a se
ajunge la lichidarea
focarelor război și
încordare de a asigura pe continentul
nostru o colaborare ronnică între toate
națiunile
colaborare care să permită fiecărei
națiuni o dezvoltare liberă independ
corespunător et indépendante conform à
sesésir et à ses
ASP